cCARTHY.
JEFFRIES.
DAVID SCOTT, JEFFRIES.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY WALKS OFF
THE --
>> HE DOES NOT LOOK HAPPY.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY WALKS OFF THE
FLOOR -- I'M SORRY, WALKS UP THE
FLOOR RATHER.
MATT GAETZ, HE NEEDED HIM TO
VOTE YES NOT PRESENT.
>> HE'S TRYING TO CONVINCE HIM.
HE APPEARS TO BE TRYING TO
CONVINCE MATT GAETZ TO VOTE YES
AND NOT PRESENT.
>> ALSO, RIGHT, IF HE COULD GET
LAUREN BOEBERT TO CHANGE FROM
PRESENT --
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN HIM DOING
THIS PERSONALLY ON THE FLOOR.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN DOING IT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, BUT UNTIL
THIS MOMENT WE'VE SEEN HIS
DEPUTIES DO THIS.
THIS IS IT.
THIS IS DO OR DIE FOR HIM.
>> THAT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A GUY
SAYING YES TO KEVIN McCARTHY.
>> WHAT A SIGHT TO SEE.
>> INCREDIBLE.
>> THIS IS QUITE A SIGHT TO
BEHOLD.
KEVIN McCARTHY NEEDS ONE VOTE TO
BECOME SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
MATT GAETZ DOES NOT LOOK LIKE HE
IS WILLING TO AQUEOUS AND CHANGE
HIS VOTE FROM PRESENT.
>> THERE WAS SOME GUY IN THE
BACK TO YELL AT GAETZ IN A PINK
TIE AND ANOTHER MEMBER PULLED
HIM BACK.
>> McHENRY SEEMS TO BE TRYING TO
TALK KEVIN McCARTHY DOWN A
LITTLE BIT HERE.
McHENRY OF COURSE A KEY ALLY WHO
MADE A NOMINATING SPEECH THAT
MADE IT SOUND LIKE THIS WAS A
FORGONE CONCLUSION.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> HE LOOKS DEJECTED.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> COMPARE THAT TO HOW HE WALKED
IN THERE SMILING.
>> THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY HAD --
I'M SURE ALL YOU GUYS WERE
HEARING THE SAME THINGS THAT I
WAS HEARING.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GOI